we need to have these hard truths
enslavement rape torture working to
death we've convinced ourselves that we
are the only nation in the whole of his
treatment who's only ever done good my
opinion is based on reading and learning
all of these facts and that's not right
the legacies of the past have shaped our
society for more than a century Britain
was this chief slave trading nation in
the Atlantic world British ships traded
about three and a quarter million people
across the Atlantic Ocean so what
happened to those people and slave meant
rape torture working to death it's hard
to imagine the Empire's economy without
slavery without the slave trade and it's
not just because the slave trade was
particularly profitable it's that it
provided the labor in the Americas that
made everything else possible it's a
period where sugar for instance goes
from being a luxury to being something
that everybody was using every day
cotton which was grown by enslaved
people was fundamental to the industrial
revolution in Britain that's absolutely
transformative for the Breton
written legislated to end the slave
trade in 1807 and that came into force
in 1808 but didn't outlawed slavery
itself in its own colonies until 1833
and that act didn't really fully going
to force until 1838 were heralded with
these ideas that Wilberforce rolled into
the Parliament important there are a lot
more incidents before that that led to
and they were led by people of color we
look at people like we are known then
you realize that it wasn't just one
person saving people it came to an end
in a in a process that led to a lot
British self-congratulation and very
rapidly a story was created that
emphasized British abolition and not
British responsibility we use history to
make ourselves feel good about ourselves
history is a place we go for a
recreation not to ask difficult
questions and what that means is if
history is a place of comfort you need
to remove from it all of the facts all
of the episodes that are uncomfortable
that a discomforting the curriculum
tends to focus only on quite narrow
parts of this history so I think a lot
of children in our schools are learning
about the the trade in enslaved people
the the Atlantic slave trade but they
tend not to learn about slavery itself
and certainly not slavery in the British
colonies what I lived in England as a
graduate student in England you could
not get a room full of people together
to talk about these subjects it was just
not something that was taught even
you know at the university level on a
very regular basis my opinion is based
on reading and learning all of these
facts which came after my my formal
education and that's not right
[Music]
the legacies of the past are actually
have shaped our societies and
discrimination is is present in all
industries all societies history
performs are different and I think very
worrying function in Britain compared to
other countries we don't use our history
to ask questions about how our nation
came to be what it is and that means
this tree of empire means this for the
Atlantic slave trade
it means the history of the horrific
violence that under cut Empire all of
Planets gets in the way of history being
a place of comfort if we're always told
that white history is history and the
narratives are told from whites
perspectives then we don't really
appreciate what actually happened we
need to have his hard truths we've
convinced ourselves that we are the only
nation in the whole of history who's
only ever done good and we honestly
believe that and people get hurt when
you suggest Britain like every other
country ever has done some good things
and some bad things we've come to
believe in a fairy tale and we call it
history